STELLAR PERFORMANCE OF THE
DEMOCRATS LOOKING SMALL AND
PETTY IN COMPARISON BUT WITH 22
DAYS UNTIL YOU’RE THE ULTIMATE
JUROR EARLY IN THE ELECTION
TAKES PLACE, LET’S GO BACK TO
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL WHERE
JOE BIDEN MUSTERED UP THE
COURAGE TO LEAVE HIS BASEMENT
BUNKER FOR A FEW HOURS.
IN FACT, JOE LEFT HIS HOME STATE
OF DELAWARE TODAY IN A RARE
OCCURRENCE FOR THE WEEK, FRAIL
DEMOCRAT.
HE WAS OVERWHELMED AND AT
ONE POINT HE CONFUSED ROBERT
BYRD WITH TED KENNEDY AND THEN
ANOTHER POINT THAT JOE COULD NOT
REMEMBER SENATOR MITT ROMNEY’S
NAME REFERRING TO HIM AS THAT
MORMON.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU MAY REMEMBER, I’VE GOT IN
TROUBLE WE WERE RUNNING AGAINST
SENATOR WHO WAS A MORMON.
THE GOVERNOR, OKAY?
I TOOK HIM ON AND EVERYBODY SAID
AND WAS ASKING THE QUESTION.
>> Sean: THE MORMON GUY, THE
MORMON.
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT, AND DOWN BY THE
THING, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER, THE
THING.
GOD, THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING.
THAT’S HOW BIDEN’S DAY BEGAN AND
IT ONLY GOT WORSE FROM THERE.
MR. JOE 30330, FAILED TO COMPLY
WITH A CAMPAIGN WEBSITE AND BY
THE WAY, MAYBE SOMEBODY ON THE
STAFF MIGHT WANT TO REMIND THE
EVER FORGETFUL JOE THAT HE IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
HE’S NOT RUNNING FOR SENATOR.
HE KEEPS FORGETTING, FORGETS THE
DAY OF THE WEEK, FORGETS WHAT
OFFICE HE’S RUNNING FOR.
HE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, NOT
SENATOR.
SOME.
SOMEBODY REMIND HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER,
THAT IS WHY I AM RUNNING.
IF I’M RUNNING AS A PROUD
DEMOCRAT FOR THE SENATE.
SO VOTE, VOTE!
GOD BLESS YOU.
>> Sean: CAN SOMEBODY TELL
JOE, BY THE WAY, NOT A REAL
WEBSITE AND JOE, YOU’RE RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT, NOT SENATOR.
BY THE WAY, THE SENATOR, AND THE
MORMON GUY IS MITT ROMNEY, NOT
SOME MORMON GOVERNOR.
NOW, SADLY, WHAT WE SHOWED YOU,
THAT’S FROM A COUPLE HOURS
TODAY.
EVERY TIME THAT JOE ACTUALLY
LEAVES THE BASEMENT BUNKER AND
STAYS OUT PAST 10:00 A.M., WELL,
DISASTER ENSUES.
HERE’S A QUICK REMINDER.
>> LOOK, TOMORROW IS SUPER --
SUPER THURSDAY, I TELL YOU WHAT,
I’M RUSHING AHEAD AREN’T I.
WE HOLD THESE TREES TO BE
SELF-EVIDENT.
IF ALL AND WOMEN CREATED -- OH,
YOU KNOW THE THING.
YOU AGREE WITH ME, GO TO JOE
30330.
WE CHOOSE TRUTH OVER FACTS.
PLAY THE RADIO, MAKE SURE
TELEVISION -- EXCUSE ME, MAKE
SURE YOU HAVE THE RECORD PLAYER
ON AT NIGHT.
MAKE SURE THE KIDS HEAR WORDS.
POOR KIDS ARE JUST AS BRIGHT AND
TALENTED AS WHITE KIDS.
>> DONALD TRUMP -- IT’S NOT
HYPOTHETICAL.
>> Sean: THIS IS PRETTY
SERIOUS, BY THE WAY, THESE ARE
WAY BEYOND AN OCCASIONAL
CAMPAIGN GAFFE, AND I AM
BEGINNING, WELL, I’M MORE THAN
WORRIED THAT THIS MAN COULD
REPRESENT A CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER TO THIS COUNTRY.
HE IS OBVIOUSLY NOT CAPABLE OF
LEADING.
HE HAS BEEN HIDING THE ENTIRE
CAMPAIGN AND THE CORRUPT MEDIA
MOB IS COVERING FOR HIM.
JOE WANTS TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA,
THAT WOULD BE THE TOUGHEST JOB
IN THE WORLD AND AT TIMES JOE
DOESN’T SEEM TO REMEMBER THAT
HE’S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
OR WHAT STATE HE’S IN, WHAT DAY
OF THE WEEK IT IS.
IT DOES ANYBODY REALLY BELIEVE
THAT IF ELECTED, JOE BIDEN WILL
ACTUALLY BE IN CONTROL OF
ANYTHING?
THAT BRINGS UP ANOTHER SCARY
THOUGHT, THAT WOULD BE HIS MOST
RADICAL.
VICE PRESIDENTIAL RUNNING MAKE,
KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE THE ONES IN
CHARGE, THAT’S KAMALA HARRIS,
BOLSHEVIK BERNIE, AOC, BY THE
WAY, THEY ARE SAYING WHAT THE
STATED PLANS ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM THE COUNTRY.
COURT PACKING, ENDING THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER, STARTING
THE PROCESS TO BAN THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
D.C., PUERTO RICO, STATES, OH,
FOUR MORE DEMOCRATS SO YOU HAVE
A DEMOCRATIC RUN SENATE IN
PERPETUITY.
IT WOULD BE THE BIGGEST POWER
GRAB IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY.
IF THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS, WHY,
THEY HOPE ALL THE 11 AND
50 MILLION PEOPLE DIE GOT
AMNESTY, THEY’RE HOPING THAT
THEY WILL VOTE DEMOCRATIC.
ACCORDING TO CHUCK SCHUMER, HE
SAID IT, EVERYTHING IS ON THE
TABLE.
AT LEAST ONE ONE AND PULLED IN F
LEFT ACTIVIST GROUP, THEY POSTED
ONLINE ON HOW TO DISRUPT AND
SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY BY
FORCE IF THE 2020 RACE IS TOO
CLOSE TO CALL.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT COMING
UP IN A SPECIAL REPORT.
FIRST, HERE’S WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD TO SAY ABOUT
HIS STRUGGLING DEMOCRATIC
OPPONENT AND HIS RADICAL BASE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SLEEPILY JOE BIDEN, NOT A
NICE GUY BY THE WAY, NOT A NICE
GUY.
PEOPLE SAY OH, HE’S SUCH A NICE
HE HAD A VERY BAD DAY TODAY, HE
HAD A VERY BAD DAY YOU SAW WHAT
HAPPENED.
IF I EVER HAD A DAY LIKE HE HAD
TODAY, THEY’D SAY IT’S OVER.
WE HAVE SOMEBODY RUNNING WHO IS
NOT 100%, NOT 80%.
HE’S NOT 60%.
WE CAN’T HAVE THIS, AS A COUNTRY
WE CAN HAVE IT.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, A TRIBUTE
TO THE GREAT RESEARCHERS AND
SCIENTISTS, THE NEW THERAPEUTICS
THAT THEY HAVE DEVELOPED TO HELP
PEOPLE OVERCOME COVID-19 IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
WE ARE ON OUR WAY TOWARDS A